Space medicine.
Is a thing.
And no, we’re not talking about medicines
made of compounds discovered on Mars.
At least not yet.
We’re talking about the drugs you would
need to survive in space.
It’s a little more than an Advil, I can
tell you that much.
Turns out, getting to and living in space
does some pretty crazy stuff to your body.
Astronauts on the International Space Station,
live and work for months at a timein a microgravity
environment, which is sometimes called zero
gravity .
But the term ‘zero gravity’ is actually
a misnomer, because earth’s gravity is still
acting on the ISS.
But doesn’t that mean the space station
is being pulled back towards earth?
YEP.
Astronauts float because the spacecraft, and
everything on it, is technically in freefall.
The ISS is orbiting the earth at a speed that
perfectly matches the earth’s curvature,
so it’s constantly ‘falling’ towards
earth, but will never hit it.
And I thought rollercoasters were terrifying.
So, microgravity is GREAT for all kinds of
scientific purposes--but your body would need
some help handling it.
If the blast off into space doesn’t give
you nausea or vomiting, it’s likely that
your first entry into microgravity will.
Our bodies have a specialized way of keeping
our balance with our vestibular system, a
series of canals in our inner ear.
In microgravity, our way of navigating through
the physical world, of sensing up or down,
is totally thrown off and may cause us to
feel nauseous.
So astronauts may take anti-nausea drugs to
get used to the environment.
While motion sickness is so common in space
that it has its own name--space motion sickness--
we see similar issues out on the open sea.
Ben Lecomte and the crew aboard the Seeker
Vessel are on an expedition to gather data
to raise awareness about ocean health.
As he swims across the Pacific, he and his
crew aboard have already experienced motion
sickness.
Another challenge Ben and astronauts share?
Bone density loss.
His body’s ‘weightlessness’ in the ocean
is surprisingly similar to the microgravity
environment aboard the ISS.
See when we move our bodies back here on earth,
on dry land, gravity is constantly pulling
on us.
This makes our muscles and bones stronger,
even when we’re not explicitly exercising.
But in space, our muscles and bones quickly
become weak and start to deteriorate because
there’s little resistance for us to work
against.
One way astronauts on extended space flights
combat this is on a special treadmill--they
have to exercise an average of two and a half
hours a day, six days a week to keep themselves
healthy.
But a long-term stay in space could lead to
a loss of 1.5% bone mass per month--and it
takes years back on earth for your body to
get back to normal.
In addition to exercising, and taking calcium
and vitamin D supplements, astronauts also
take a medication called Bisphosphonate once
a week to prevent bone loss.
But let’s get a little freakier than just
baseline health maintenance.
In addition to your regular antibiotics and
decongestants and antidiarrheals, astronauts
may also use drugs that improve their cognition.
On the ISS, astronauts have to complete extremely
long and difficult tasks, like fixing some
crucial component of the space station.
To help them stay alert, astronauts aboard
the ISS may take a drug called Modafinil.
It’s actually not a stimulant in the way
that coffee or even cocaine is, it’s a class
of non-addictive psychostimulants called a
eugeroic--a wakefulness enhancer.
It’s used here on earth to treat narcolepsy
patients, and for patients like astronauts,
works to enhance attention, executive function,
and learning while they stay awake for long-periods
of time.
I really could have used some of that in college.
Last but not least, space crews also carry
tranquilisers.
Space can be pretty freaky, and if any member
of the crew were to lose it a little bit,
their fellow ISS inhabitants would need to
make sure they weren't going to do any harm
to themselves, the other astronauts, or the
station itself.
If someone were to go a little Space Odyssey:
2001 on the ISS, their companions are encouraged
to bind their wrists and ankles with duct
tape and administer a tranquiliser.
So that’s fun.
For more space stories, make sure you subscribe
to Seeker!
And to see how Ben’s swim through the Pacific
compares to the extreme environment in space
- watch this latest episode here.
This expedition will help us learn more about
our largest ocean’s marine life AND the
human body at the same time!
Pretty cool.
Thanks for watching.